[Music]
[Music]
for the last week or so depending on
when i actually get this video out the
pts has been live and open to the player
base to try out the new game mode called
countdown
now before i get into it when i first
heard about the new game mode being made
my heart sank not because i didn't want
any more game modes i mean this is
exactly what the division 2 needs but
because i knew whatever was created
would be absolutely crucified by the
community
people would be expecting the game mode
to change everything to be a new game in
its own right
there has been no single game mode to
date that has changed the overall feel
of the division i can already hear
people screaming out survival and while
i agree survival was fun it wasn't a
game changer
personally i played it enough so that i
understood the mechanics and could
consistently extract after that you'd be
lucky if i played it once every few
months and at this stage i haven't
played it in years
yep that's right sorry splinter shield i
haven't even participated in a survival
saturday one day maybe though i'll
probably be one of the first players
knocked out after all this time
so my expectations around this new mode
were a little lower than most i was
looking forward to something that i
could jump into from time to time like
survival or last stand not something
that will completely change my division
experience
and although it may be a little
lackluster i'm not gonna lie i see a lot
of potential with countdown
as a reminder countdown is a new eight
player pve game mode
two cells of four shd agents are
deployed at a power plant to prevent a
lockdown
there is a 15-minute timer that agents
are working against where they need to
secure the site before it's too late
when a couple of objectives have been
completed the agents can then extract
but this is when a familiar enemy makes
themselves known the hunters
while countdown is intended for eight
players and there is matchmaking you can
start with a smaller group and even run
it solo
however there isn't any scaling down for
smaller teams you will still be taking
on the same difficulty and number of
enemies before i jump into it i'm not
going to go on and on about the bugs and
good god i certainly saw my fair share
of these because as we know this is just
a test server these are to be expected
when i first jumped in i was immediately
greeted by a number of modifiers that
were placed on the screen
these didn't really change much from
game to game but i feel like they're
probably holding back on a few for the
final release
next a giant red 15-minute timer pops up
that sends the whole squad into a panic
realising that there was some urgency
required on our part
we followed the tracker to our first
objective in this sequence we were
greeted by hyenas a fair few of them but
nothing we couldn't mow down quickly we
were then alerted of a high-risk enemy
that is now approaching
like his henchmen before him he was of
little hassle to our now squad of five
someone must have gotten lost from their
other squad and ended up with us
the next location we were sent to had us
meet up with the other sale of agents so
there were now eight of us running
around spamming our weapons this was
over before i could even realize what
was going on there were obviously a few
people in here that had played some
rounds of countdown before because i
knew they were objectives but by the
time i made it to them someone else had
finished it
the objective now was more of a battle
against each other to see who could get
the kills first
we were then given the heads up of the
comms that we've been successful and can
extract
everyone heads over to the marker i was
expecting there to be a few enemies to
wipe as the last push to stop us but i
wasn't expecting the type of enemy we
encountered
suddenly i realized that going in blind
staying away from everyone else's
comments on this game mode may have just
caught up with me
the cockiness that everyone is feeling
after the ease of the first two
encounters mixed with the sudden
introduction of the hunters that have
been hiding within the black tusk ranks
that we were engaging meant that three
of our seven agents one got disconnected
were instantly dropped
we just ran in too fast we didn't have
to worry about the enemies dropping us
before why would this encounter be any
different
at the end of the day we successfully
wiped the black tusk along with the
hunters who were supporting them and
then extracted i can't show you any end
screens because i've been encountering
the known infinite load in screen bug
that can happen after you extract
so did i find it fun
yes absolutely there is something about
the chaos of running around with seven
other agents that really adds to the
game mode
i know this can be achieved with raids
but they're different not because there
isn't matchmaking but because they
require solid communication
countdown works with matchmaking because
the tasks required are a lot more
straightforward plus there is a little
bit of randomness at least through the
number of sessions i've played so far
more than once i came across a random
hunter while moving between objectives
and every time this happened i was
lagging behind my squad
while most of the time i didn't have a
problem dealing with it i did end up
getting separated from my group unable
to find them again
in fact most of the time i ended up
finding the other sale of agents and
just teamed up with them until the two
groups combined later on
is it replayable
like i said earlier i don't really find
any of the game modes in either game all
that replayable and what i mean by that
i couldn't really play any of the
division 1 or 2 game modes over and over
all night i would usually bounce across
a number of them
but i certainly found countdown a lot
more interesting than underground and
especially summit i only managed to
complete this one once and it was more
for completion purposes not because i
was enjoying it
i see a lot of people comparing
countdown to summit i admit the few
objectives we've seen so far are quite
familiar but that's about where the
similarities end
for starters the map is beautiful summit
was just bare bones 101 map construction
the game plan summit is also very static
even where you take cover feels like it
has been predefined
is there any law
from what i could tell no and i don't
expect there to be any going forward
none of the game modes up into this
point have provided much in the way of
law
do i think a pvp element should be added
no but hear me out
pvp survival worked so well because
builds were taken out of the picture
players were forced to use what they
could find or craft later on
bringing pvp into this mode would kill
it straight away the same issues that
plagued the division pvp in conflict and
the dark zone would be present here too
as the majority of players in the
division are not pvp players this would
lead to the game mode being dead on
arrival
they could add a pvp option to the game
mode like in survival but this would
require quite a number of technical
changes in order to make this work
there are so many ways a team could
ignore objectives and ambush the other
team not caring whether they extract or
not
plus the issues around the division and
many other rpgs around pvp balancing
would just end up being another sore
spot among pvp players
i mean this is why heartlands has been
created builds are being taken out of
the picture the balancing issues will be
far easier to handle
i do question the use of the timer i'm
not a huge fan of timers and games
anyway i hate speedruns and i like to be
able to have more options when playing
through content not just the build and
tactics that revolve around killing
things the fastest i tried a few options
and it really just felt like full dps
was really the only way
however in saying that the time was
never really an issue
with every game i played we were in the
extraction zone far sooner than we
needed to be
it was only really a problem when i was
running solo of which i managed to do a
number of times
running a safer build would mean that
you couldn't kill enemies fast enough so
again you're forced to run glass cannon
and other high dps builds
but i imagine this will change when the
difficulty is altered there is no way
they'll be leaving the difficulty as it
currently is
the mode will either be tweaked to hell
so it's more challenging or we will be
given difficulty options when setting up
a new game
because right now it's far too easy for
eight players or even four
the loot drops are fantastic if it stays
as it is and you can continue to select
the type of loop that drops this is the
best place to farm in the game
especially because of the hunters at the
end
i will however say that it's pretty
anticlimactic once you get to the
extraction
once the black tusk and hunters are down
it just kinda ends
pure chaos for five to ten minutes and
then it just stops
but for all we know there could be an
option to carry on to a next phase for
example with increased difficulty
summing up the pros and cons
a player madness is fun half the time i
think i was shooting my fellow agents
because there was so much shooting going
on
matchmaking actually works because of
the simplicity of the objectives
no forced pathing i got lost tons of
times usually ending up with the wrong
team
the map looks great
and of course you get a ton of loot in
the short period of time
cons
the time limit is this really needed
this affects the builds that are viable
same old enemies nothing new
the map although beautiful could become
repetitive
the difficulty is far too easy
and realistically there is nothing
really new it's just like playing a
larger version of a mission except with
eight players and minimal to no story
i have a couple of suggestions that
could improve the experience that may
have already been considered but wasn't
released in the test version
the time limit should go it only takes
away from the experience
add difficulty options
a larger variety of objectives a larger
variety of directives
add a couple more map variations
more random events like the hunters
popping up randomly in the middle of the
map anything that breaks the standard
complete one objective move on to the
second objective kill the hunters in
black task and then extract
add an option to continue into multiple
phases each increasing in difficulty
with the risk of losing countdown
credits that you've gained previously
not that i know what these credits are
actually used for yet
one thing i want to say and i think it's
important to recognize is that sometimes
i and my fellow youtubers can kind of be
dicks sorry guys but it's true we can be
at the end of the day we're simply
giving our opinions as gamers on what we
have experienced and how we feel about
the direction of where the game is going
because of this a few not all but a few
have found a niche where they prefer to
focus directly on the negative side of
things rather than exploring the other
side which in the long run can have
quite a large impact on the community
anger is probably the easiest emotion to
tap into and thus get a reaction from
and because of this it can often lead to
people either coming in with unrealistic
expectations or automatically assuming
the worst
as always i urge you to go in with an
open mind and make your own opinion
i by no means think that countdown is
for everyone and it's true that it
really isn't bringing anything hugely
unique and groundbreaking to the
franchise but i think there will be a
decent chunk of players who will enjoy
this with a few tweaks i'll certainly be
jumping into it from time to time
the other thing that needs to be
remembered is that this is a pts a
number of the smaller problems will be
fixed like difficulty and maybe even the
timer in enemies etc we just need to
wait and see how much of the feedback
the actual constructive feedback that
the dev team takes on board
anyway thank you very much for watching
and i'll catch in the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh